un deuxième classe et jean louis murat
qui s'étaient exprimés jean-louis murat
c'était un chanteur jean louis murat
voilà et il s'est exprimé dans les
colonnes des inrockuptibles
à l'occasion de la sortie de son nouvel
album il en a profité pour tacler johnny
hallyday de manière très violente
on vous explique tout et on vous
expliquait jean louis murat ce parti
lors de sa disparition en décembre 2017
johnny hallyday a occupé la majeure
partie de l'actualité on se souvient des
images impressionnantes des bikers
surmontant les champs elysées pour
rendre hommage au plus grand rockeur
français ou encore des centaines de
milliers d'anonymes réunis à l'église de
la madeleine
mais si le chanteur semblait à ce moment
là faire l'unanimité il ya visiblement
un chanteur qui ne partageait pas la
peine national en la personne de jean
louis murat dans une interview aux
inrocks l'homme âgé de 67 ans qui n'a
jamais sa langue dans sa poche n'a pas
hésité à se lâcher sur johnny pour lui
le taulier faisait partie des chanteurs
minable et ringard qui ont poussé les
français à cultiver l'abrutissement en
étendard nationale avant d'ajouter une
phrase pour le moins définitive le jour
de sa mort ce fut un soulagement comme
un 6 juin 44 pour la musique
à cause de lui nous sommes passés pour
des tocards pendant 50 ans des
déclarations très dure et violente à
l'encontre d'un artiste pourtant peu
virulent
alors est ce que vous êtes team johnny
une prime et jean louis murat yakin du
team dionis souffle kelly vdo v10 qui va
nous expliquer pourquoi dans un instant
parce qu'il faut savoir que elle m'a dit
elle m'a raconté un témoin non non ne
sait rien dire quand elle m'a dit non et
si paris venait d'une famille de rocker
se disait pendant le un magnéto nisand
web bas amis célèbres auteurs oui bien
sûr à easy non ce que je voulais dire
c'est que je ne suis absolument pas
d'accord avec les propos qui sont qui
sont assis son méchant à son encontre
moi ce que je voulais seulement dire
c'est que pour moi ce qui se passe mais
que c'est là pour moi de géniale idée
n'est pas vain mot car voilà on va être
géniale idée de base alors tu comptes
des pénalités oui parce que j'aimerais
ça se voit que tu écoutes jenahi des
excuses moi le country krieber fusil
alors mais moi j'adore la dick rivers
est un vrai rocker cible téléphone ce
sont des vrais rockers il ya plein
d'idées mais c'est quoi du vrai regret
c'est un rocker de variété dans le jeu
reste est géniale idée avec ces
messieurs brésil c'est pas parce qu'on
sait pas parce qu'on vend beaucoup
disque qu'on a beaucoup de succès on
émet un vendeur qu'on a un gros coeur de
variétés alors je me dis qu'après ça
l'est non merci à toi c'est pas les
manteaux c'est dans l'âme
alors non mais non vous vous pouvez pas
passer un truc vous avez je ne vous
comprends pas ce cas il n'ya pas du oui
oui bah oui oui non et quand on vous
donnera la parole vous aurez peut-être
le droit vous voulez défendre thierry v
de v 10 actuellement
alors elle n'a pas besoin de vous
benjamin quand on entend ça alors moi
j'ai envie d'apprendre que ce qui dit
une grosse bêtise
et encore je vais rester poli et que
j'aurais bien aimé qu'ils disent la même
chose du vivant de johnny ce qui se
passe
jean louis murat est ce que les mois sa
carrière est assez relative alors arrête
avec ça je peux dire un mot est relative
à tous qu elle n est pas populaire
personne ne sait qui c'est mais en ce
week end le gros but que je ne connais
le connaît le rôle dans le bois n'est
pas hyper connue alors j'ai rien contre
lui généré dans deux zones humides et
les mairies bon ton et j'en ai assez
parce que ça ça ça fait deux trois fois
que ça arrive
et j'en ai ras le bol de tout les gens
se permettent pas aussi à des choses
après la mort des gens jean louis murat
sont longues a dit ferme ta [ __ ]
gueule
j'étais fan de johnny chan encore fan de
johnny pour moi c'est le patron
franchement et je vous dire c'est pas
parce qu'on a beaucoup de succès comme
un chanteur de variété voilà
gyneco sauf que oui c'est ça me fait
penser au clash d'avant je pense qu'il
ya un problème de compréhension est ce
que vous avez quelque chose à dire
en fait c ils s'affrontent sur le
langage et les façons de parler c'est
vrai comme les mecs du quartier avec les
gens et oui mais parle de johnny johnny
qui pense que peut-être il est plus
intelligent que lui mais en fait ils
parlent juste différemment que lui mais
et parlait pas exact mais la donne et
l'insultent la de jalousie je pense que
jean louis murat je le connais c'est
simplement l'artiste a conclu jacques
haman de citer un seul titre
vous avez donc un appel à tous les
dollars
elle ne groupe abba l'avez vous clamez
le groupe abba vous quel est le profil
un peu aigri quand même on a toujours
l'ombre de johnny pendant cinq ans voilà
c'est ça je pense que même temps que je
lis pas la lui va pouvoir peut-être l'un
non il n'était pas là au tour de jim
alors attendez attention non ça fait
s'il vous plaît dessine moi je trouve
que premièrement on l'a dit dans le
lancement à l'occasion de la sortie de
son album
voilà donc pour moi c'est pour faire du
buzz deuxièmement affaires du moment où
tu clash quelqu'un qui est décédé il n'y
a pas si longtemps que ça je trouve ça
honteux et troisièmement justement
lorsqu'on clash toujours quelqu'un qui
est plus élevé parce qu'on est en
dessous
en quoi les plus